hey guys this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so i've been working as
a professional trader on the option
market for the past
six years in hong kong and i've decided
a few months ago to create my youtube
channel
because i wanna share with you all the
different things that i see at work
and i want to show you how to do it
yourself so basically how to make
money on the markets because this is
what we are doing
as traders and i want to bring you a bit
more
in to my words i mostly talk about
technical analysis but
i want to start talking with you about
options because
those instruments can be very very
useful
to build up very nice and profitable
strategies
so let's get into it
[Music]
in today's video guys i want to show you
the difference between your position
which is buying gamestop shares all
right so say you have
100 shares you know i know 100 chess is
a lot you know but we can take 10
but it doesn't you know look the same so
let's keep 100 and the good thing is
that the multiplier on the option is 100
so you know it makes it easy to compare
so you have 100 shares your p l is
something like this basically gamestop
goes to 800
which i think we might see this year
you making 60 000 us dollars but
you have some downside risk because your
position is a delta one position
you are long the stock so you can lose
everything
you can lose your national your national
is 60 000
u.s dollars instead of that there is a
strategy
that is very used in finance i use it a
lot i mean you know it's a very very
common structure that we trade
with very big sizes every day on every
every share every index it's called a
risky
so what is a risk a risk is a strategy
that consists of
selling a put and buying a call so let's
say now you don't have any shares
buying your call you know what it is
because you guys
like to buy calls so you have this
payoff so for example you buy a 300 call
because you are convinced that gamestop
would be trading above 300
in july i'm doing everything on the july
maturity
but now you can also sell a put guys and
i know that a lot of you
are doing this retail investors are
selling more puts than they used to
before
because they noticed that it's actually
a very nice trade to make
it's like you know usually professionals
are selling options and retail
is buying options but we've seen the
flows are changing a lot of retail
investors are now starting to actually
sell options which is let's be honest
the smart thing to do
on the long term all right selling those
options
is actually more profitable in the long
term than buying them
this is why professionals are selling
them and you guys can sell them too you
just need to know what to do
and here you go back to your charts and
you need to find some levels
that you are confident we won't be
trading below you know you don't choose
your options
randomly you need to find levels where
you think that gamestop is not going to
be traded below
so for example 50 is one of them but 50
is too
low and 110 is my support level here is
one of them too
so you can do it with 110 so you go
on yahoo finance and you check 110
option price it's worth 19.5
so this one is useless we don't use it
guys i put a 0 here and we're gonna sell
put strike 100
and you sell one contract so 100 options
all right and the price
is we said 17.5
all right so now you can see that
basically you sell a put
so that your call is free and the beauty
about that
is that basically you can see your
payoff so only the put is something like
this
so the put makes you lose money below
100 because you're selling it and the
call
is making you money above 300
so right now let's say you do 1.2
it's not changing much it's still zero
cost risky
and you are actually able to capture
the same upside performance sixty
thousand dollars to the 800 strike as
you used to
with your shares but your downside risk
is lower you can see that not only you
losing only 12 000 if we go to zero
which is less than sixty thousand with
your hundred shares
but most importantly you don't use
everything if your scenario is correct
what was your scenario let me remind you
guys your scenario
is that we won't be trading below 110
all right this is my scenario
but i don't think we will be trading
below 110
in july i think 110 is gonna hold of
course i might be wrong if i'm wrong
then i take a loss by doing this
strategy
but this is how you combine technical
analysis
support levels resistance levels with
the option strategy and
once you combine those two you can build
some
very efficient strategies option
strategies
that can actually help you to realize
the same gains for
lower risk because here if gamestop
trades at 125 or even at 100
you're not losing money and this is a
scenario that you consider
is possible so you don't want to lose
money in this scenario so instead of
having shares
you have a risky once again this is my
risky
payoff so max i lose 12 between 100 and
300
nothing happens and above 300
i have the same payoff as i had with my
shares it's slightly
different but it converges to the same
payoff
60 000 so that's it for me
i just wanted to show you guys that you
can use options to replicate
almost the same payoff you would have by
buying shares
but you can modify your uh risk
configuration and
you can combine this with technical
analysis
so that you build some strategies that
fit uh
what you think might happen in the
future so yes that's it for me i hope
you enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything
new and stay close to 4. i'll see you
guys